- Ladies and gentleman,
William Spank Horton.
Please show William
Spank Horton some love.
(audience applause)
- Hold the applause,
hold the applause.
Why did you say Will?
- Well your name is
William Spank Horton.
- But, this is my brand,
this is my stage name.
I want you to call
me by my stage name.
- You know what, you're
absolutely right.
I'll start,
- Thank you sir.
I'll start over.
(synthesizer music)
- Ladies and gentleman,
Spank Horton, Spank Horton.
(audience applause)
A friend, that I
should call a brother,
because I've know you that long.
You're from Philadelphia, P-A.
- Yes.
- Right, what part of
Philly are you from?
- Nicetown.
- Slash, North Philadelphia.
- There you go.
- Where the gangsta's
be at, bang-bang,
y'all know what it is.
- Okay.
(audience laughs)
There's no need to
threaten people.
- Okay, I'm sorry.
(audience laughs)
- Now, you were the
guy, in college,
that actually boo-ed comedians.
- Yes.
- So then you start
doing comedies.
- Yes.
- Were you every fearful,
of running into a
guy like yourself?
That I like to call
the ass(bleep).
- Yes, yes.
- Why did you boo comedians?
What would you think?
- 'Cause on college
campus, I was known to be
the funny guy, so whenever,
I always had my same
seat at every show.
It would be like, you see how
you got these rows right here?
I be right in the
middle dead center.
Right in the middle, right
there where my man at,
- So they could see you?
- So they could see me.
- Eye contact.
- Right.
- And then everybody look at me,
if the comedian
ain't doing good,
everybody look at me
like, it's that time.
Then I would just stand up.
Ahhhhhhh.
Booooooooooooooooooo
(audience laughs)
Then everybody join in and
the comedian got off stage.
(laughs)
- What a dick, what a dick.
(audience laughs)
- But mind you, at this time,
I didn't know it was
a craft and all that.
This was before I was
thinking about it.
I just like, yo every
comedian should be funny
if they gon' get on stage.
- Yeah, yeah.
What sparked the decision
to pursue stand-up comedy?
- Kings of Comedy
came out in 2000
and I remember leaving
the theater and
couple people saying,
when are you gonna get on stage?
- Really?
- Yes.
- So was there a
weird transition for
you when you tried
to start doing comedy?
Was there a weird
separation from being the
the instant funny,
within the group,
and then trying to
be the guy on stage?
- It was a transition
regardless.
It's gonna be a transition
'cause you in front of
people you don't know.
When you in front of your
friends, they know you
so they know you
about to be funny.
But when people pay,
and they don't know you,
you got to be funny.
(audience laughs)
It was definitely a transition.
It was definitely a
transition though.
- I've seen you grown and
develop from the comedian,
that at one point had the
three to five minute sets.
And those five minute sets
grew to 10 minutes sets.
So take this stage and
do what you do best.
I'm proud of you man,
I'm happy for you.
Next level brother.
Go do what you do.
(audience applause)